looking back at the weirdest and
riskiest movies of 2019 some were
fantastic and others just didn't work
either way these films featured plots
that left viewers scratching their heads
here are some of the most baffling
movies of 2019 heads up some light
spoilers ahead writer-director re asters
midsummer avoids many horror tropes to
tell its tale of full core and Florence
Pugh is nothing short of a powerhouse in
the lead role mid Samar is one of those
films where you can tell things are
going to go majorly sideways from the
beginning aster loves to leave dangling
threads for his characters and his
audience to pull on with lots of half
answers sprinkled throughout sans fun
regardless of what your theory is about
the movie might be there are most likely
clues to support them and plenty of
clues that point in the opposite
direction
velvet buzzsaw is one of those movies
that makes it tough to truly tell
whether what you're watching is actually
any good it has all the pieces in place
starting with a solid cast led by Jake
Gyllenhaal and Rene Russo Dan Gilroy
directed it fresh off the dark and
grossly satisfying Nightcrawler it
centers around artwork coming to life
and murdering critics and that basically
sums things up on the other hand is
anything in velvet buzzsaw really
happening or is it all just an extremely
meta commentary on the way we consume
and critique art what's even going on in
this movie there are a lot of questions
raised and not a lot of answers given
but if you like watching good actors
playing bizarre characters velvet
buzzsaw is for you very few directors
have debuted with their first feature
quite like Jordan Peele did with 27
teens get out he had high hopes to live
up to with the sophomore effort us and
he delivered another fresh thriller with
a ton of layers if you want to get crazy
it didn't quite strike the same nerve as
get-out but it inspired plenty of hot
takes on its release everyone in the
main cast plays a double role in the
film their regular selves and their
tethered version Unleashed from the
secret underground society where they've
been kept for who knows how long as the
film goes on and you learn more about
what the tethered are it becomes
apparent why they're a force to be
reckoned with Lupita Nyong'o steals the
show delivering an impressive dual
performance even after you've seen it
multiple times us will keep you guessing
and have you theorizing for hours Robert
Eggers followed up as 2015 film the
witch with 29 teens equally perplexing
the lighthouse it's shot in black and
white and an almost square aspect ratio
no widescreen here
it's a two-man show with Robert
Pattinson and Willem Dafoe playing - men
manning a lighthouse together and it's
completely bizarre when you watch the
lighthouse there are about 50 different
ways to interpret it maybe everything is
literally happening maybe some of it is
maybe Pattinson isn't real
maybe Dafoe isn't unlike the witch the
lighthouse never really gives you any
answers still it's an impressive film
that a group of people could watch at
the same time and all come to wildly
different plausible conclusions the
perfection is a body horror masterpiece
that will have you squirming in your
seat it's also a film that will keep you
guessing until the very end even if
things do wrap up a little more neatly
than many of 2019 s weirdest films the
plot centers around two women in a
prestigious music academy what starts as
a simple tale of revenge becomes more
and more insane it's exploitative and
tough to watch but it definitely hits
the right buttons for people who are
looking for a bizarre viewing experience
something is wrong something is wrong
with me featuring killer performances
from both allison williams and logan
browning the perfection is creepy weird
and oddly satisfying one of the best
films of 2019 is also one of its most
baffling legendary korean director bong
Joon hos parasite is full of twists and
turns and you never quite know exactly
where it's going the film starts out as
a commentary on wealth and social class
and a story in which one lower-class
family begins to push themselves into
the life and social standing of a much
wealthier family about halfway through
however things take a dramatic turn and
parasite becomes more of a horror
thriller as secrets are revealed and a
series of dramatic revelations occur
joon-ho employs dark humour so perfectly
that it keeps you off balance while
watching parasite you never know if you
should be smiling or just plain
horrified not every baffling movie of
2019 was good and serenity never quite
gels that said it's still worth a watch
just for one particularly memorable and
bizarre plot twist if you want to see
Matthew McConaughey and Anne Hathaway
work their way through some truly
strange material serenity is a good way
to do it
after Hathaway's character asks her
ex-husband played by McConaughey to
murder her current husband he wrestles
with the idea and you'll probably think
you know where this plot is going from
there fun fact you don't when the twist
arrives odds are pretty good that you'll
find it just doesn't work that well but
man does it try serenity really swings
for the fences and many of the bizarre
plot twists further confuse things
rather than clearing them up check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the belt
so you don't miss a single one